[Music]
so youtubers
are known to do crazy [ __ ] to get
followers on their channel not all slap
like a [ __ ]
right there we go right this is one of
them
see the views we need the views
[Music]
it's like you're slapping a chick's butt
like you need to have like finesse like
oh
got around it a little bit too like let
it be structure
you know yeah here we go again
you guys try it at home
oh wow the focus the passion you're
gonna fart
it's like a [ __ ] 6.3 magnitude over
here
you know he's pushing hard all right i
have a story here you guys have a story
he's [ __ ] pushing the most random
[ __ ] thing to say after clapping
you're gonna fart
we know how easy found he had a fart
face though oh no
are your hands no cute my hands are not
a little bit we're not tingling i'm in
pain i'm bleeding
yeah all right so i have a story here
uh two women were kicked off in american
airlines
all right two women were kicked off an
american airlines flight after
allegedly trying to allegedly trying to
get followers on their youtube channel
and what they were trying to do here
all right so two women were trying uh
trying to get youtube followers
they were kicked off a flight and this
is what how they
attempted to do that i'm paying
attention baby
i haven't even seen any american
airlines flights wait what was the
attempt i'm so sorry i'm
sorry okay okay they were trying to get
kicked off a flight we're gonna watch a
video there then
they got kicked off the flight okay
there is no video followers there isn't
i wish there was a video
no they're clout chasing that's all you
need to know yes cloud chasing
chasing ass [ __ ] all right got it so
what they did
clap chasing don't start
all right so what they did was one of
them bought a coach ticket and another
one bought
a business uh class ticket how much time
using my hands
you almost started another clap dude
i kind of jumped in like double touching
[ __ ]
[Music]
right before they take off the the girl
that's sitting in the coach
side she walks up to the business side
and
hides out in the foot well what is that
i have the seat right here right yeah
what
oh yeah it's pretty it's pretty big it's
roomy yeah it's dangerous
so she basically like huddles down
underneath and just kind of
curls up and starts watching a movie on
and i guess it's one of those flights
where they give you the
ipads out you know what i mean i never
went on though yeah me neither ooh
pinky up yeah it's for older planes like
older planes that don't have like the
the
screens on oh also it's not fancy so
that is she yeah it's actually
older yeah that's so good that's so good
so
she so she sits there and she starts
watching a movie and so the person
sitting right next to the girl that has
the seat in first class or a business
class is like
what the [ __ ] you know like what are you
doing you know so then
uh 30 minutes later oh so they're
because already they're already waiting
for some i think like the food to be
loaded up like there was an issue with
the flight they couldn't take off so
they're already waiting
sounds like spirits oh so this is before
it takes off before taking off
when she's already waiting and now
they're finally taxiing out and then
they they do this so the girl's in the
the footwell area
and so then uh one of the flight
attendants
in our they're making their last uh
rounds to check everyone's in their
seats or whatever and they realize it's
a full flight
and there's a missing person in coach oh
what the [ __ ] you know if there's
everyone's you know seated then
every seat should be filled so she's she
goes on the intercom
where's the bathroom yeah well there
wasn't anyone in the bathroom though
either so she was like
all right well whoever isn't in their
seats please you know sit back down
whatever whatever
so after a couple attempts to get this
girl sit back down on the last attempt
she does get up and as soon as she gets
up she gets busted
and from there whack-a-mole pop she oh
there she is
so then uh she goes back to her seat and
then that's when the flight attendants
are like hey what's going on here why is
there uh
why are you you know sitting in the foot
well and then that's when the passenger
next to the girl
uh and co you know ratted them out and
like oh they were trying to do something
and they had their phones out and the
camera's out i think they're trying to
make a youtube video
of them trying to stow away in the
footwell so then from that point on
the girl that was sitting in first class
or business class
they started shouting they started uh
feeling like i feel attacked
oh guys you guys are attacking me right
now i'm just trying to uh
fly i paid a lot of money here i have a
i have a kid waiting for me back home
you can't kick me out the flight oh
by the way they're being uh they're
being escorted off the flight
yes that's right if anyone tells me i
feel attacked
and i didn't do anything to them i'd
[ __ ] smack them in the face and i go
that's attack
true you're like a parent
i go oh that's this is jail
i feel yeah cause i'll be like oh i feel
trapped and then
i smack him and i go now i feel really
trapped i'm going to jail
like a mexican parent it's like if
you're trying to if you're crying then
all of a sudden like you want me to give
you a reason to cry
like that's the parent response oh oh
it's like psychological warfare
yeah that that reminds me of my dad ptsd
yeah
what'd your dad do he had an axe oh okay
you got you like all asian parents do
yeah
yeah treat you like a tree he's gonna
pass it down to me
um wait so so what the hell were they
trying to do i don't get it
so yeah basically they're trying to make
a video of them stowing away in the foot
well
interesting and trying to get away with
i i don't really even understand
why that tv i'm not even trying to make
a youtube video you [ __ ] boomer
it's tick tock she said she was
screaming she felt disrespected did
nothing wrong
paid good money to be there child is
waiting at home she takes her
mask off and starts shouting out and and
refusing to be
uh taken off the flight and this is not
the girl that was hiding
this is the other one this is the the
business the richer one yeah
they had a lot of money okay so have her
friend tucked away is there any
any photos of anything no photos no
videos i wish i wish i had
had some is this some kind of like like
a fetish yeah you know maybe it was a
dom
submissive situation oh you know the
foot fetish
is at the foot rest right but they had
phones out
yes yes they were definitely trying to
make maybe they were just a family
vlogger of of
s m people and then she's like look it i
got my little foot rest here today
a good little foot rest and then it was
gonna be a whole like
you know flying business class with my
foot rest wait are there pictures of
these people
no i wish i've been trying to find
actual pictures and then this
uh story originated on a blog post about
about this issue and multiple people
posted about the story
so i guess it kind of checks out in the
fact that people have i really want to
see what this like foot well looks like
yeah well i mean you guys flown business
class it's like it's really roomy
yeah there's extra leg space no but like
i want to know
how it looks so with another human being
there
as the flight attendants walking up and
down the aisle like how are they not
seeing this chick
you could put a blanket over or whatever
yeah okay the way that i
um i flew right recently is that
if you're on the side some planes have
two business class
stacked onto each other like like this
side by side yeah
so you think it was one of those if
someone else is sitting like where
anthony is it might be like this
or it's staggered or it might be like
this right yeah we're like one oh yeah
this looks like that too yeah
yeah like a train yeah wait 69
yeah there's 69 business classes it's
like there's like a wall in the middle
this is like
you could see that like hey what's up
yeah you have the option of
yeah yeah if you sleep toward each other
see that's the thing i wouldn't
it's too risky to do something on a
flight like that because it's so
intense and you know flights and tsa
things like that
they don't sound like they were
minorities personal opinion oh
that is an actual fact because i'm sorry
watch they are i know right no i know we
need to find out how do we find it
because i
don't know there's no pictures but it is
true because
white people often um are not afraid to
break a few laws stuff you know i mean
like they they feel like they have
nothing to lose i mean no
yeah we feel like we have everything to
lose and they do whatever they want it's
like that stand-up bit i forgot who was
saying but they were like at the protest
at lax
and then like oh white people were bold
and they're like standing up to the
police
and all the other minorities were like
oh [ __ ] you're going to talk to them
like that
right yeah i guess i'm confused why they
decided they could get away with it
before a takeoff i think it was part of
the stunt the stunt is for them to
do the entire flight so it's a flight
from my uh dallas fort worth to miami
so it's about like a three-hour flight
and i think they're just trying to do
the whole thing
watch a movie and and not be in their
seats or whatever i don't know man
maybe the narrative of the their video
the youtube video they're trying to make
was that
she's a stowaway she she was uh flying
free
in business class probably here's my
question if you were the witness would
you have snitched
like literally they're holding up the
flight they're looking for this [ __ ]
person oh [ __ ] yeah you know they're
right
after an original delay of like no tell
her to go back to her [ __ ]
seat so we could go yeah right i'll look
over like hey they're looking for you
same i don't care if she comes back and
like
plays or whatever right let's take off
first for fun
it also depends on how cute they are
right like tag me
you know like what is this video yeah
what if they're like really
old then i want to see what happens yeah
right i wouldn't say anything i'd just
be like hello
right if they're like like you know
senior citizens
freaking kids who want attention then
i'm like okay let's
you know let's wrap it up but if it's
like you know they're like 85 year old
and
grandma's on the bottom that's cute
this might be her bucket list moment oh
true they kind of like how they like to
get arrested and stuff like as part of
their bucket list
sure yeah as a stone sense sort of
little old girlfriends that want to shut
it up
go viral how cute like old family louise
if you have gotten arrested we don't
need to bring that up but if there is a
reason for you to get arrested in the
future
what do you think it would be i'm not
i'm a law abiding citizen now
probably like urinating in public or
something donating in public yeah i
don't think you gotta rest for it but
like in some
you can can you exactly they don't just
slap you with the ticket
no i think you'd be oh you become
yeah no it's really i don't do that it's
risky wait what about
for girls too what about girls yeah i
think it's no no yeah
you could even flash it's called like a
public exposure or some [ __ ] like that i
mean
because you know we've like popped some
squats in parking lots honey
just maybe not me ever yeah now we as in
never girls
are my friend we yeah we have not been i
just like
yeah my yeah i'm okay in that case
no i [ __ ] in public all the time [ __ ]
for sure
what [ __ ] for sure what
[ __ ] bare minimum okay
yeah i have class when it comes to
number one that's for my only fans
only poops
[Music]
you